Hold on, my setup is all weird.
Hold on.
One second.
Ah, one second.
Why is this so weird?
What's so...
Ah!
Oh, everybody, welcome.
Let me grab my controller too.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Everything is changed.
All the things are different.
Everything is different.
Star Creator!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Star Creator!
Happy birthday!
For my stream deck, I just...
I just updated my stream deck.
There was like a one update that I remember I really didn't want.
I don't remember what it was.
So I never updated it.
No, I just did it.
So I was like, I don't know what else to do.
Oh, hi-ya!
Oh, hi-ya, oh, hi-ya.
But it fixed it.
I can use my stream deck again.
Ghost in the game are so cool and scary and pretty.
I might be into ghost.
The work on the Iron Mouse collab.
Oh, it wasn't a collab with Iron Mouse.
It was actually like a, what do you say?
A surprise for her, but I'm glad you liked it.
Thank you.
What was that?
Mm-hmm.
So!
We're back.
Silent Hill.
Spooky, spooky.
I'm like in the mood for a spooky game today, not so i'm like i want to watch people play spooky games but i don't want to play against spooky game myself here i am playing a spooky game myself congrats to the wisps who watched the christmas karaoke i'm passing that your due date do any of kids mince kids share her birthday no
There's no children.
There are none.
Hand me the controller.
Yeah, it's one of those days where you're like, well, I never had like an older brother, but you want like your older sibling to like play a game and you watch the game.
That's how I'm feeling today.
I don't want to be the streamer.
I want to watch the streamer.
Silent Hill F for me.
Silent Hill F more like Silent Hill Sword Trick Royale.
No!
But you are streamer, I am streamer.
Today though, I don't know, maybe because I was watching other streamers.
And I was just like, ah, this is what it's like to be, you know, just chilling and watching the streamer.
You know what I mean?
Look, give me the controller.
Okay, I give me the controller.
You control, you control them.
I watch.
Nah, we'll play.
Okay, good.
My controller is working, though.
Wait, what's wrong?
What happened to my Omamori?
What?
Omamori, where?
Try downloading it.
Wait, what?
What happened?
They patched it.
I like how it said the white Seifuku, but I still have the rabbit.
Oh, wait, isn't it Steam update right now?
It's Tuesday.
Or wait, no, isn't that at 6 p.m.
ESC?
What?
It didn't say anything about the rabbit uniform.
That's so strange.
I have a lot of issues with Steam.
Sometimes with, like...
This shouldn't matter here, but, like, the cloud not sinking.
I have quite a bit of issues with that.
Oh, well, we're not...
It kind of sucks, though.
I don't think I was using those Omamori, though.
So, the, or the Pianni one.
I think.
And I wasn't using the white Seifuq.
Hmm.
Let's see what's going on here.
Oh, yeah, see, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
Well, we're not okay, because we're in Silent Hill, but...
We're mostly okay.
Okay, I gotta remember how to do stuff.
Okay, there is durability on these.
Oh my gosh, I gotta get more weapons.
Or I just leave, you know, whatever.
That's Dodge.
And then, like, right...
No, that's...
That's like the lock-on.
This is the attack.
Big attack.
Dang, girl.
And this is quick.
Left trigger is your focus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The strongest pipe in gaming history?
You think so?
I don't know.
I think a stronger pipe would...
I think I've seen pipes that last the whole game before.
I thought I heard footsteps.
So scary.
I have to go over this way.
So let me see real quick.
I guess maybe a journal?
No.
I'm trying to see where it says our goals.
Our goals, our goals, our goals.
You were following Shu, right?
loser went ahead of us so he was just like oh catch up you know i'll i'll you gotta follow me and then he just ditches us he's kind of the worst he's kind of awful but it was we tried exploring this way there was some scariness going on in there so i'm just gonna go this way
right I'm scared of this way though look we got like the the scarecrows there was like stuff about sneaking up maybe one day I'll get it and I saw something also walk that way walk that way it did though it did no time for jokes I'm scared what are you looking at what's your name Hinako Guys,
I think Oh, here's my map Okay, yeah, we gotta go that way, I believe Because that's the way Shu went And then he's smart And knows how to, like, walk around cars We don't know how to do that Where can I watch your Iron Mouse collab?
I don't I think there's a miscommunication I don't have a collab with Iron Mouse But I was invited to a fan uh how do you say a fan project of her song where we sung the song can i not go
what's down this way though well we've gone that way let's just keep going let's just keep going to the new area
i don't like that why Oh there she is I knew I told you I told you there was somebody over there Oh my god so scary Oh my god as soon as I step up Stop it right now
Stop it right now What a creepy scarecrow It's wearing our uniform Guys I think I had like Okay Don't...
If I get this right, if you know, spoilers for the game.
I think I had, like, a big brain moment.
So I saw a screenshot of one of the bosses.
And she had twin tails, just like Sakuko.
And I was like...
Uh-oh.
But don't...
Don't confirm nor deny.
Don't say anything.
And I was like, oh no.
Because Sakuko died, though.
I'm scared how do I run being a quirky girl oh my god don't see me
left stick okay are three nice one that
was pretty fancy we're leaving we're leaving okay good stuff we're leaving whoa this place is we're praying we're praying okay hmm excellent dodge i have can we wait what to oh i need That's right, for the random Omamori.
But, look, we still have the pink rabbit costume, so why don't I have the white Seifuku?
On the road again.
I can't wait to be on the road again.
So maybe I need to go down.
Probably.
Maybe Sugaoka.
Yeah, Shu, what the hell?
Oh, he is here.
Wait, how, where have you been?
Yeah, this is...
...I'm always going to do something like this.
...I'm not sure what's your...
...you know, it's not like that.
Then...
...together with each other.
Yeah!
Oh.
...I'm just going to do it yourself.
She thinks you smell.
These guys really plump cheeks, huh?
Our journal has been...
Space Wars!
This is a game that Shu and I played together when we were kids.
Basically, aliens known as the Galactic Imperium would arrive in UFOs and droids.
And we would fight them to protect the town.
Wait, this is so cute.
The art is so cute.
Playmates would come and go.
We called them new recruits and fallen ones, respectively.
And in the end, Shu and I were the only ones left standing to combat the Galactic Imperium.
I see.
Why isn't Shu with us?
This guy sucks.
Oh, let's get some meds.
Let's look around a bit for some meds as well.
Anything in here?
cute
um I don't want to go too far back because of a lady you know what we're fine
we're okay maybe what's down creepy oh no I can't go this way why are you gotta be kidding me of course that's the that's the gosh darn truth huh oh no oh jesus oh no who did this thank you classic silent hill yeah classic classic everyone always makes a mess and mcs don't know how to crawl around them Phil,
thank you so much for the vibe, gift, and thank you.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh.
What is...
So some areas are like super ultra red.
Why?
Do you guys think I should go up or around?
Oh my god.
Well...
Let's see, I guess.
Ah!
Oh my god!
I tried to...
Oh.
Oh my god!
You will not be able to be able to free yourself from an enemy's grasp if they successfully grab you.
When grabbed by an enemy, your health and sanity will drop significantly.
Be sure to stay aware of your surroundings.
If your chosen story, being grabbed by enemies will not cost your current max sanity.
Okay, nice.
Well, thanks a whole lot.
trying to sneak up on you.
Hate!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh.
Where are you?
I dodged too soon.
It's fine.
Oh my gosh, please.
Dodge!
Ah!
Die!
Die monster!
So scary.
They're so creepy.
In like the best way.
Oh no, my weapon!
Uh oh, okay.
I'm glad she tells you though, shoot.
Oh yeah, that's pretty bad.
She does tell you though, that's kind of nice.
Um, those look like sticks.
Saw another playthrough where the character came around from the other side of the house and didn't see it coming.
Too spooky.
Way too spooky.
Why don't everybody...
All houses should have pipes.
Just saying.
Oh.
Are we going...
Oh?
Okay.
Survived my first Sabrina Carpenter concert.
There were so many people I panicked and ran out.
When I came back, A guy fainted?
You went and saw the Sabrina Carpenter?
She's so hot.
Wait, I can just go inside?
Wait, I'm scared.
I don't want to be indoors.
I want to see Sabrina Carpenter.
She's so sexy.
But you did it.
I'm scared!
If I die, I die.
Uh-oh.
There's blood in there.
Don't like that.
You know what?
I'm gonna switch to my other weapon just in case this does crack.
I can... I don't like it one bit.
I don't like it one bit.
Oh!
Oh, no, good.
won't budge.
Okay, you know what?
That's fine.
Maybe for the better.
Actually for the best.
Wait, that's someone in the bed.
I don't know, I'm sexy.
Okay, Sensei.
Wait, can I... This thing's gonna... For sure.
Oh.
Okay, just kidding.
sensei can i have all your iron pot pipes please please steal pipes even pipes can i have all your their pipes okay we gotta find a key and then and then it will wake up oh godly i hate this i don't like being inside can i unlock the door the lock's broken okay just Copper!
We'll accept anything!
Anything but gold!
I've learned from Minecraft!
Gold is too soft, breaks too easily.
What was that?
Oh, my camera locked for a second.
I was too scared.
I'm using every...
Like, I'm using my camera to the max ability.
Oh my gosh.
What's this?
Kudzu tea.
Slightly thick.
Drink mid by dissolving kudzu powder in water.
In this region, ginger and freshly... I'm drinking ginger right now.
Ginger and freshly pressed juice are added to enrich the flavor.
Freeze it before drinking.
Slowly restores health and current max sanity.
What's my health at anyway?
Some stuff over here.
Arate.
It's pleasant crunch makes it never boring to eat.
You cannot hold any more items.
Uh-oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
I will...
I'll drink this then.
What's in here?
Whoa.
Okay.
Open.
I didn't expect that.
Oh.
Okay.
We'll just close that back up here.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Aha!
I got it!
Oh, whoops.
It's interesting that you have to, like, kind of direct the camera to where you, like, the thing you want to look at, you know what I mean?
She didn't even say anything about it.
You guys, is it...
Are you guys also hearing the creaks, or is it just me?
Wait, I threw away the drink?
I didn't consume it?
Oh.
The creaks and the...
Like, the...
Like, sounds like someone's upstairs.
It's a discard.
Oh my god.
No!
I'm so stupid!
Well, I don't think it would have let me do anything.
Oh, yeah, see, there it is.
No!
It wouldn't have let me take it, though, I think.
Oops.
if you back out you can use the item first ah okay okay
you have the toolkit to repair your I do
uh-oh durability look at it it's all messed up I didn't notice that I had gotten bent I should look for a new one before this one gives out let me try uh let me see this then um equipment items first aid toolkit fully restores toolkit here we go restores equipped weapons durability like max oh wait i have a here okay oh
okay nice i don't hear any creek but i do hear a creep oh my gosh greg go thank you so much for the hookah super thank you
well i didn't use it on this one because i wasn't sure how much it would repair It's okay.
It's okay.
Wait, which one am I on now?
The other one was, you know, yeah, we'll get more.
It's okay.
I'm real spooked.
Don't...
Shit, I knew it.
I was about to say don't wake up.
Oh, my God!
Jump scare is imminent.
I know!
My plushie finally arrived.
I'm so glad.
Thank you for ordering it.
What if we leave?
I knew it.
I tried to kill her when I had the chance.
You not go, why didn't you kill her when you had the chance?
Maybe it's nothing and you're fine.
Yeah.
Check the room.
Look how bright and inviting the outdoors looks.
so spacious so many places to go
I thought I would unlock the drawer and she would wake up then did not expect her to be gone now I'm so scared okay wait I'm gonna do something which might be a little silly to you all I'm gonna go save
I'm gonna go save I don't want to go through the panic all over again We're safe scumming a little bit At the moment
Who?
Who is here?
Who is around?
You better get out.
You better go away.
I don't want to deal.
okay okay okay we're fine we're fine asterisk
okay okay all right save point is in sight
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay now if i die all i have to do is walk over there i'm okay actually did i have died so i but i guess it's more of like, uh, I have died before.
I guess it's more of, like, uh, I don't know where it will load me back at, so we'll just, just for safe measure.
You know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's giving so spooky.
Why are we in here anyway?
I didn't really have to come in here, huh?
I mean, I guess I do.
What if it's a really good item?
Maybe it's worth it.
You've died before, you're a ghost.
Okay.
All right.
How do I avoid getting grabbed?
Like this.
Walk and jump.
Walk and jump back.
Where did she go?
Oh.
Maybe she loved.
Square?
Oh, wait.
I'm...
Is that B?
No.
X?
Ceiling?
Oh, true.
I'm so scared.
Okay, I'll be brave.
I'll be brave.
X to lock on.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
I'll be brave, I'll be brave, I'll be brave, I'll be brave, I'll be brave, I'll be brave I'll be brave!
Local doctors note Even now the trust given to the longstanding physicians of the IY family is unshakably strong When I spoke to the eldest working member of the family at a gathering I was astonished by their outstanding bounty of knowledge Though as they discussed the details of their practices with me I got the hint
I got the hint that they might still be using controlled substances in their treatment.
However, I think it's best to look the other way in this situation.
Okay.
While it is now illegal to produce the cloudy rice wine known as Doburoku, Doburoku, people across Japan were once free to make it as they needed.
Perhaps operating within the gray area of legislation between traditional and modern medicine has always been the role.
Of local physicians here.
If it's wine, how bad is it?
I was going to say moonshine.
Yeah, I was thinking moonshine too.
Okay.
Okay, time to press.
Time to go back and then go back into the game.
And I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Leaving me.
Nope.
No one's there.
Don't do it!
Why would you think somebody's there, huh?
Why would you...
But the loot?
I know, you're right.
I don't know why this game scares me so bad, you guys.
Wait, so it opened the door but didn't?
They could have a pipe.
There could be a pipe in there.
There could be a gun!
There could be a pipe or a gun!
Oh, the game just saved for me.
Okay, awesome.
Oh, oh.
I'm peeping.
There is a window.
I guess I could maybe jump out of it.
Who knows?
Um, anyway.
I'm too scared to function.
At the moment.
Why would we go inside?
Should not go, please.
Have some common sense.
My friend.
Girl, please.
Why would you go inside this room?
Okay.
Seems like a whole lot of nothing.
I don't even see a weapon.
I hear that.
Sorry if the audio is like so low.
It's pretty loud for me, though.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh!
I don't like that.
Okay, maybe it left out the window.
Actually.
Oh.
There's like drugs and stuff on the ground.
Claw marks.
What do we have?
Oh, another Omemori.
Increases Max health.
Thank you, CS2.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Ray Mack, thank you for the five gifted.
Oh, I didn't see.
Sorry, I did not see.
who rated but thank you so much Ducky thank you so much for the gifted I'm scared Doburoku is made with rice chewed up and spit out by Miko oh wait I have heard of that before then Yaku ni tats yaku ni tats ne
I'm scared I'm scared of game game scary game spooky autopsy report undetermined cause of death cause of death case zero nine body was astonishingly malnourished and the calvarium had split open like it had burst from the inside what's the calvaria what is that the cranial bones have been hollowed out and filled with insect eggs later identified as belonging to various species including locusts grasshoppers and crickets Heart of the skull,
okay.
Thank you.
No evidence to suggest that they were put there by human hand.
Seemed to be planted by insects naturally.
Highly unusual behavior considering the current harsh winter temperatures.
I'm sorry, what?
We think the bugs just like...
We think like 20 billion ants just lifted up the man and carried them over.
Yeah, another corpse to come through with an inexplicable cause of death.
At least this one was easier to stomach than case 0-8.
All bodies with unexplainable causes of death are kept secret and swiftly handed over to the police department.
In turn, the police department immediately disposes of such bodies without so much as a customary glance.
Additional notes.
This man was suspected of blaspheming against religious doctrine.
He seemed to bear some kind of grudge against the Inari faith.
It's always the same with the...
It's so...
so higurashi it's always the same with these strange corpses after all after all they can only be one outcome for not paying reverence to oinari-san oh no new kishi 7 is new kishi 7-ing oh no
oh yashirozama no oinari-san oinari-san
okay oh i feel like i'm about to get jump scared like Crazy as soon as I walk out of this room.
Holy.
Please.
Please don't.
Please be kind.
Can I leave?
Oh wait.
Maybe I did leave.
I have some reason doubt.
You can't be jump scared if you're prepared.
Do you know Oinari- Oinari-sama?
Yes, every- So I used to live in a place that had like...
It was...
I guess I can say it because I don't live there anymore.
I used to live in Jiu-Gaoka.
And so every time they say, or every time I read Ebisu-Gaoka, I'm just like, oh, so similar to Jiu-Gaoka.
Okay.
I'm just gonna jump scare.
Ouch.
Just run, just go, just run.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Run, run, run, run.
Red went through!
Please!
Oh my god.
I pressed the wrong button even.
I did the heavy attack instead of the not heavy attack.
Just leave.
Just get out of there.
Just go.
Gosh.
She's just screaming in there.
Okay.
We don't need to go back to Sensei's house.
Dinko's house.
Which way was Dinko's house?
Oh yeah, we did see this little box and we're like, what the heck?
What's she doing over there?
I like the way they dance.
Let's try going in.
This might be even worse of a situation, but
oh my god, so did she.
Okay, we had the same idea.
I'm so sorry.
This is your turf.
My bad.
Can zoom out of the map?
Oh, I guess that's true, right?
There we go.
But...
Uh...
I think it's not...
What is the heck?
Um...
Written yet.
Okay, let's go down this way.
There was another entrance.
to the fields.
Henry, welcome back.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the 50 gift.
Holy moly.
Thank you so, so much.
Come here.
Oh, my God.
Come on.
Oh, this area seems kind of not great to be fighting in, huh?
Because it's like...
Where'd you go?
Oh, there you are.
Do you see me?
Can I get in there or no?
I can't tell, to be honest.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this kind of area sucks a little bit.
Maybe?
You definitely get trapped in here.
Yeah!
Dodge!
Oh, no.
Actually, go forward!
And beat her up!
Ah, dodge!
Dodge!
Ah, shoot.
Oh my gosh.
So scary.
Ah, dodge!
Oh, we got her.
Yay!
Oh, so scary.
So they come out of the mud.
Ike.
I hear another one.
Whose house is this?
Hello?
Heal?
Everybody's so low.
You think we need to heal?
Oh, yeah, we are.
Goop.
I don't want to keep...
I don't want to go into any more houses.
I think it's a bad plan.
Going into houses.
All in favor of not...
Let her to home.
I no longer recognize my husband.
He gets blackout drunk most days now and when he's drunk he turns violent.
I don't think I can keep on living this way Not with his cruelty a day after day after day Where did the kind man I met when our marriage was being arranged go my eldest child is only three years old And I have another growing inside me.
Oh my gosh Life is too hard to keep living, but I'm forbidden to die
you asked, no matter what it is.
But this will be my first and last selfish act.
Please forgive me.
Oh my god.
I hate this.
This is why we are not entering people's homes.
Okay, let's go this way.
Japan did arrange marriages.
Oh, yeah, sometimes.
Oh, hello.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, I'm kind of surrounded a little bit.
This is not good.
I'm going to run.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'm really surrounded.
Wait, I'm super surrounded right now.
Okay, hold on.
This is so bad.
Wait.
Okay.
Let's go this.
Let's not go in the field.
Let's...
I think...
Oh my gosh, okay.
Yeah, let's not...
Go in there.
Oh, whoops, wrong button.
My bad.
We'll just keep heading...
this way.
Actually, what's down here?
Okay.
Quiet.
I like how the flowers are still blooming, no?
So pretty.
I love Hydrangea.
Are these more houses I can go into?
No, thank you.
Potatoes!
Let's go.
This seems like a house I can enter.
Maybe not.
Sandage!
I will take that.
I hear walking makes me so uncomfortable sorry i know i keep checking the map oh okay there we go wow okay wrinkle damn you own this town oh sheesh okay i hope i can't go in here yay
You know I'm scared when I don't want to explore.
You know it's bad when I'm like...
I don't want to go inside.
I don't want to go... I don't want to...
I don't want to... I don't want to look around.
Me.
I look around everywhere.
Me right now.
I don't want to look around at all.
Let's go down this road.
Let's avoid the horror.
Whatever's growing in here.
Hadao!
Wait, that's so cute.
That's so cute.
Hadao.
Why are you scared?
You're already dead.
Hinako's not dead.
She's very alive and she can die.
I have all that pressure on my shoulders.
Keeping her alive.
You know how hard it is for me?
A dead person?
To try and keep someone alive?
When I failed at doing so?
Oh, Inari-san?
Wait, what is this?
Oh.
Okay.
My bad.
Don't know what was going on there.
was a little fox, but it was not.
It was actually a man.
My mistake.
I see things.
Wait.
You see the stuff in the water?
Oh, but... Okay, with the way the camera was, it looked like things were walking past.
Oh, see?
You see in the water?
It looks like... I thought things were, like, walking over there.
The reflections, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think there's anything walking.
I guess we'll find out.
So scary.
One, two, baby.
Why is the music getting like this?
There's somebody here.
Oh, there they are.
Hello.
Hold on.
Um, I guess we...
We are going the right way though, so...
A bravery song.
Bravery song!
I've never seen her so spooked.
Atmospheric stuff like this really, really gets me good.
It's like the scariest thing for me.
Hey, hey, hey, I was locked on you.
Oh, oh, oh,
oh.
My gosh.
Oh, shit, I was...
Oh, I caught it.
I actually caught it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh, that was kind of, that was more smooth.
Okay.
I'm getting used to it a little bit.
Oh, my pipe though.
It's halfway already.
Okay.
Phew.
Yeah.
Okay.
Onwards and upwards.
Anything in here?
Like a pipe?
Surely.
Oh, I took it!
Wait, okay, back?
items
um wait why can't i hold the toolkit i'm so confused there's literally a slot for it do you like outside loot what do you mean check out this fancy new inside homes loot it's new and fancy no no i don't want inside home loot use from your lv
Wait, so can I grab it now?
No.
Wait, why can't I take it?
That's so strange, right?
Isn't that not so weird, though, that it doesn't just put it into the slot?
There's also an item limit.
Oh, okay.
Well, let me see what...
I had one...
Not Ramanay.
Slightly restores health.
when used continuously.
I had one drink.
Oh, the divine water.
Fully restores current, max sanity, and reduces sanity damage taken for a set time.
Ah.
Maybe I'll eat the crackers.
Or I can...
Oh, or...
Oh, wait.
I can just drink something, too, right?
Like, I don't have to fully dispose of something.
if I, like, eat this, I should be able to take it now, right?
What?
Okay, we'll eat the Araday then.
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
What is that?
Sorry, I am... Oh, first aid kit.
What you're there?
Some items stack.
But, like, it's...
I'm so confused because it's, like, in my...
Thing?
So I'm like, why can't I just grab it?
You know what I mean?
It's confusing me so much.
But I'll eat this.
My sanity is not bad.
And neither is my health.
But I guess...
You have 8 out of 8 items.
Okay.
Toolkit's important, though.
Toolkit's very important.
Am I going the right way?
Yes.
It seems I am.
Nani?
How side loot is there for anyone who needs to take against side loot is just stealing because being responsible member of society?
Um, what was that?
Yeah, uh, Nani?
Uh, yeah, Nani?
Did I go the wrong way?
Oh my god!
What do you mean?
There's not just just just just mannequins or
Nani, gasky!
None of this.
I'm so sweaty right now.
Okay.
I want to save, but I did not see anything to save with.
It's so sad.
Wait, what I was going to do was...
You guys think I should use the toolkit on my other pipe?
Okay.
I'm wondering.
Not yet.
No.
I mean, we'll just continue with this one for now.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, okay.
Take that for sure.
Wait.
Oh, this is a...
Oh my god.
I'm so stupid.
I have to go all the way back around.
Maybe it's eating the other mannequins.
Oh
Minto phantom Who do you like more than me?
Huh?
Should I go save?
Probably not.
My auto save.
Oh my god, I see them walking in the distance.
Oh my gosh, I don't want to go that way!
I don't want to go that way!
Guys, that was a rhetorical question.
Don't actually answer it!
You're gonna make me sad!
Okay, I haven't gotten a save though since the house.
That's why I'm worried.
Let's go save.
I go save, I go save, I go save.
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god!
Please!
Not hot dog!
Not hot dog moment.
I'm never gonna beat this game at this rate.
Ah!
How did it see me?
Why did it have to see me?
Did it hear me running?
Is that why?
Yeah, leave.
Ugly.
Oh my gosh.
I heard the hot dog.
Wish I could sneak past.
Maybe I can.
Act natural.
Don't look.
Okay.
Well, I did save.
I feel a little bit better now.
I don't feel better.
I don't feel better at all, actually.
Hi!
Oh!
Turn around!
Maybe they have bad eyesight.
Well, oh, that's the case, isn't it, right?
But they have bad eyesight and they can hear you.
More than they can see you, right?
I forgot about that.
Because their eyes are, like, all messed up.
Right?
I can walk through this, right?
Hinako, don't be stupid.
Oh, Toriko, thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you.
Ah!
Silent Hill.
What now?
Oh my god!
Ah!
I tried dodging!
I did.
Yeah, stupid.
There we go.
Okay.
I think.
No.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm so screwed right now.
I'm so screwed right now.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Ah, shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I'm so screwed.
I'm so screwed.
You guys, uh, we're screwed.
We're so screwed.
There's three of them.
Oh, God.
Oh, golly.
Okay.
Wait.
You know what?
That's fine, actually.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I got stuck!
I got stuck, for real.
Just keep going.
Just run.
Actually, just run.
You know what?
Oh.
It would do that.
Okay.
Let's run.
Oh, just run.
Just get out of here.
Maybe I can handle her a little bit better here.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, I can't get the timing on it, though.
Oh my god!
Oh, don't come over here, please!
Please!
Spare me!
Yeah.
Ouch!
Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow!
Oh shit.
Oops.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Uh...
Take, take, take.
Oh my god, wait!
What do you mean?
My weapon will break!
Uh-oh.
Already?
Oop,
oop, oop.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's over?
Is it?
Is it over?
Oh my gosh, please say yes!
What was in here?
Nothing?
Wow, that's rude.
Oh, I didn't think we were gonna live that.
Guys, good job.
Good job, team.
I didn't think we were gonna live through that at all.
Holy!
Both of my weapons are pretty busted, so let's use the toolkit on whichever one, I guess, suppose.
Whew.
Okay, um, you know, we can just keep on keeping on.
Ah!
Oh shoot, wrong button.
Can I go you put me into a false state of security?
I'm just gonna run.
Oh wait, there's something here though.
Grab it!
Chocolate!
Get
the chocolate and go?
Okay, maybe we're safe?
Did someone say chocolate?
She was like, oh, it's finally over.
Hinako, you put me in a false state of security!
It's your fault!
Hmm.
This way?
Wait.
No, I need to turn this way.
Go into the red.
Oh, we're going into the nasty.
This way?
Does he mean?
Sure wish I could find a save right now.
I don't know if the game saved.
I didn't...
I have...
Oh, the game just saved!
Yippee!
Okay.
Shoo, why can't I hear you?
Where are you?
Oh my god, the game was like, you just went through it.
Here's...
Another pipe!
Oh, Ryan, now we have three.
Where in...
This place is like a farming town.
No, why can't we find like a machete or something?
The game was like, you've been through it.
Don't worry.
We'll reward you.
Another toolkit.
I wish, though, I could find a save.
I was going to say a save so I could do an offering.
Okay.
Let's see.
Is there anything that I can get rid of?
Ghost?
Why do I have two different kinds of...
Does this, what, does it, what, that's strange.
I only have two different kinds of bandages.
What's my health like at anyway?
I will use one.
Nice.
Japanese didn't invent machetes until 1997.
It can only stack up to three.
Okay, well, maybe now...
You guys, oh, my bad, wrong thing.
You guys say I have like a...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, so it is seven out of eight now.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
Okie dokie.
It's locked.
Cut scene.
That doesn't make me feel good.
And in this area?
Oh no.
Uh oh.
Wait.
What do you mean here it comes?
What do you mean?
Wait.
Holy!
What?
Oh my god!
What's the storehouse?
This one?
Here?
Holy!
Oh my god!
Oh,
he's disgusting!
He looks angry.
Let's loop him.
Can I loop him?
Oh!
Okay, awesome.
What's the storehouse, Jule?
Open a window, where?
Here?
Oh.
I'm good.
Oh, but I need the key first.
Oh, okay, okay.
Good thing I was trying to grab before.
Loop up up.
Okay, let's loop him again, maybe.
Oh, I gotta crank it.
Oh, my God.
Are you...
I don't like this.
Ah!
We were so close!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, I'm gonna die for sure.
Does it save my progress or do I have to do that all over again?
Dang.
I'm cranking it.
I'm not even gonna save.
Oh, surely!
Or, like, I'm not gonna heal is what I mean.
Because, uh...
I feel like...
It'll just... I could just...
Yeah, I know.
Oh, there he is.
We'll just redo it if I die.
It's okay.
We'll just redo it.
This might be bad.
Oh my god, I really have to do it all over again.
Oh
my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
We're dead.
Wait, I kind of want to see the death animation though.
Holy cow!
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Okay.
All right, cool.
Very nice.
Dang.
Okay.
this out, huh?
I feel like looping him is the best option, but Patrick really let himself go after SpongeBob's death.
Ah!
Oh!
Is there anything else around here?
Oh yeah, the toolkit.
Which we got, we ate.
Or we used a bandage.
I mean, honestly, that puts us in a pretty good position for this fight, But...
Gets me every time.
Shoot, where are you?
That was a sick kill.
I don't want it to happen again though.
Dude regenerates, so fighting him just waste weapons.
You're right to loop him.
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
That's what I figured.
I was like, this guy is...
I think at our current stand.
so this guy is too meaty.
Okay, I know what to do, though.
Ish.
I don't know if this is the right... This seems like the right place to loop him.
I probably just have to get him, like, right here and then I go do it or something.
Okay.
Let's try again.
I have heard people saying that this game sometimes gets, like, like for some of these bosses?
I'm kind of scared about that.
Takes a long time to recover.
Oh, he takes a long time to recover from attacks too.
If you dodge an attack, it will give you more time to crank.
True.
True, true, true, true.
Okay, here we go.
This game is Silent Souls.
Why is it like this is two scariest genres ever?
Mintos First Souls like honestly actually though this guy looks like a he looks so cool and nasty
yeah he's pretty dick I and I can't tell oh oh dang I misread what his attack was but it's okay I'm gonna keep looping him come this way Come this way, big boy.
Come this way, big boy.
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
Oh, okay, yeah.
So I can avoid that attack, it seems.
It doesn't reach me here.
I'm trying to get him over here, though.
Okay.
Maybe this is enough time.
Oh, it's not enough time!
It's not enough time at all.
Okay.
Very cool.
Oh, he turned around real fast.
Where?
How could you tell where I was, actually?
Oh!
Oh, ew.
Okay, I was too close for there.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God!
He drank!
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
I'm still...
I'm learning!
Oh!
Okay.
Ouch!
F stands for Dark Souls.
Okay.
This door?
I really need to like loop him, get him over more.
Oh gosh, wait, I don't know.
I don't know if this is enough time.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I don't know, I don't think so.
Oh, I don't think so.
What do you mean?
Hinako!
This is life or death, please!
Walk in!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
A slide can hurt.
I know, it took away half my health, pretty much.
I've already experienced it.
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Maybe?
Maybe now?
I don't think so.
Oh, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe.
Come on, come on, come on!
No, stinking way.
Girl.
Did I get it?
Come over here.
Oh, he doesn't...
He doesn't want to work how I want him to.
I want to loop him, but he's not letting me.
At least the hay kind of, like, blocks him a little bit, so it's not so bad.
He's like a big cat.
I wish.
Come, come, come, come this side.
I think I should have gone there, but it's okay.
I'm trying to get him over a little bit more, right here.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come to go, come!
Just need him to move a little bit more.
There we go.
Okay, maybe now?
Oh my god, please!
Please!
Oh, I was... Nope.
I don't think so.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Oh, he sucks.
Ooh!
That was close.
wish there was a way I could put away my weapon so I could like run a little bit faster you know oh shoot ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch oh this is not good
Uh-oh, he's right here.
He's right next to me, isn't he?
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Oh, I got it!
Yes!
Okay.
Third time's a charm, baby!
Okay!
Are you kidding me right now, please?
You're not going to get up!
You're not going!
Oh, wait, oh, I have to hold these now too?
Oh, you're kidding me.
Oh, this...
Oh my god.
I bet there was good loot in there though.
There's nothing actually?
No way.
That's so rude.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, he's actually here.
Thank you for the capsules.
I used a couple bandages.
I probably didn't need to use so many bandages, but...
It is what it is.
The best loot is being alive.
So true!
Wait.
Oh.
My lights flickered.
Good job, gamer.
Thank you.
Even though it wasn't so great towards the end, but that's okay.
I thought this was a place to save.
Oh, well.
Oh, there's a place to save.
I'm blind.
We pray.
Freaky.
Oh, it only gives us not so much, though.
I'd rather eat it.
Anything over here?
Oh, I can relax a little.
Get some sanity back.
What's my sanity looking like?
No, their sanity's fine.
Okay, wait.
Just to recap, the top flowers are sanity.
Middle's my health and bottoms my stamina.
And then the moon is my weapon durability, right?
Okay.
Yes, okay.
Oh, that leaf?
That leaf scared me.
Oh, shoo!
Shoo, don't do that!
Why would you just be standing there, man?
What's wrong with you?
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Shoo, what's wrong with you, you psychopath?
This looks like it's readable.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Oh, more bandage, nice.
We're looking around a little bit.
What's this?
Emma!
A wooden plaque.
Place it back in a hokora after writing your wishes.
Upgrade ability!
Okay.
I'll do that.
Gasoline?
Hikashi.
Oh, it's a...
Shinako Senori is okay, but how's Vito?
By the Vito, I got to see you in San Diego on stage like a...
Oh, I get to see!
I was like, got to see me!
Get to see you in San Diego on stage like a barbecue!
Thank you!
Fully restore stamina and prevents stamina consumption for a set period.
We'll hold that off for now.
Wait, let's go back to the shrine then.
from the future.
What's the guy's name?
In Steinsgate.
Tudor.
John Tudor.
Is that his name?
Titor.
John Titor.
That's you.
That's you right now.
You can always offer some stuff.
You don't... Yeah.
I was thinking that...
Okay, hold on.
You can use a blank Emma and Faith to pray at Ahokura and increase your max health stamina and sanity.
You can also increase the number of Omamori get equipped at a time.
So how do I do?
Do I...
How do I do?
Oh, and here it is, pray.
Seriously, I need 500!
Oh no!
1500 for Omamori slots.
Yikes.
greatly restores current sanity or current max sanity but it's only 20 divine waters 50 wait okay hold on we're doing math so it's like 110 100 and oh wait okay wait 110 for these two and then 90.
so 300 380.
So I don't even have enough to I wouldn't, if I sold everything, I wouldn't have enough.
Wait, was I off by a bit?
Oh, it's 280?
Wait.
Is that what?
280.
It's taking up your inventory.
I know.
But I could eat it.
This one greatly restores my health.
Oh, and you have 100, so 380 total.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
We have to save it for Silent Hill F2.
I'll get rid of the ones that are just like the...
You can... It will not be consumed for a set time or whatever.
Because I feel like I'm really bad at it.
using at like timing those kinds of things so this one only slightly restores your current max sanity but sanity will not be consumed when using focus for a set time but i i'm not gonna be able to time it i think like i don't know how long what is a set time you know so we'll get rid of that thank you and let's go get the higashi shu you're gonna be the death of me It lasts like 30 seconds.
Okay, okay.
If nothing, gamble everything.
Cool!
Too scary.
I gotta hold...
What if I have no bandages?
What if I have no pills?
I gotta take my pills.
Is there anything else in here?
No.
Just the candy.
Okay.
I'm enjoying the break.
Is there anything over here?
There might be something on top.
A brief moment of rest.
Just a bunch of hay.
Just a whole lot of hay.
Okay.
I usually enshrine one from a stack of three, so I have room for another.
That's... smart.
I don't actually quite understand the sanity factor of this game yet.
What does it, like, affect how you...
How you fight?
Or, like, what does...
What's gonna happen to me?
We'll do one.
And we'll do one.
And we'll do...
This one also fully restores stamina and prevents stamina consumption for a set period of time.
This one fully restores your stamina.
Sorry.
Did I say salmon?
I think I want salmon.
It's no eternal darkness, I've just dreamed.
Salmonella.
This seems a little fishy.
Fully restores Max.
Greatly restores health.
Greatly restores sanity.
You know what?
I'm gonna get rid of all the ramen there.
I think it's okay.
Okay, we're at 270.
And that also free...
Oh, wait.
Did I...
Kikashi's really good if you have trouble with stamina.
That's what I was just thinking.
I was just like, if it fully restores stamina, I feel like that's pretty good, no?
Ah.
Health.
This is also sanity.
I'll get rid of it.
What do I...
Wait, what do I...
Hold on.
I get rid of it.
What do I have for sanity?
Ah!
I don't have any items for sanity.
So just in case I'm really in a pickle where I need a sanity...
Oh, I guess the pills help a little bit.
But I might want to keep something for sanity just in case.
The stamina in this game gets brutal sometimes.
I'd recommend holding on to any sort of stamina helping thing.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I think this is fine for now.
Oh, let's pray.
And we pray.
Where are you at?
Okay.
Oh, my bad.
Okie dokie.
What you doing over there, Shu?
Don't, why are you kissing turtles?
Turtles have Salmonella?
That was the first I've ever heard that before.
This is the first time I've ever heard that before.
Natsukashi, here.
Relatable.
I was a young boy.
I had to cry and cry.
I remember crying.
You can't imagine anything.
I can't imagine.
I have a long time I have a long time.
No.
You have to do anything to keep your mind and put your heart into the bad way.
Relatable?
I thought he just jumped into the water.
There's...
Stop showing off.
There's literally a bridge right there.
Why are you playing around so much right now?
This is not the time.
He's giving you Satoshi and Keiji vibes.
It's the bat.
Have you ever been?
This is such a difficult moment.
I remember all the memories I remember.
Now, every one of them is very much.
If it's going to get it, I'll never die.
I'll be sure to talk to you about it.
Aibo.
Thank you, Aibo.
Imagine getting partner-zoned.
Why does this keep happening?
Escape?
That's...
Memories of getting lost.
There was this one time where I played hide-and-seek with a bunch of my friends when I was young.
I got so excited and ran far away because I didn't...
didn't want anyone to find me.
Eventually I got lost around here.
I was sobbing and hollering and walked the wrong way for hours.
Actually, I was told later that it was the exact opposite direction of my house.
Even a town as small as this felt huge for me as a kid.
I realized that I knew nothing about the town.
Even these fields seemed to spread out endlessly into the horizon.
Oh!
Okay, I could really rely on you, but now, I will
mysterious note the field that's all misty is really scary I keep thinking someone's there but it's always just a scarecrow with a creepy face but there's one scarecrow that's actually not scary the only reason it's making a scary face is because it's got a thorn sticking into it and it's hurt it's got a big thorn up its butt so all you have to do is take the thorn out and it'll tell you which way to go to get close to the really scary scarecrow's.
Someone said there's a monster who's only pretending to be a scarecrow that likes eating little kids.
Look at the little doll.
What's here?
Oh, the music is too...
Freaky!
It's too freaky!
Wait, if I go back this way, is there anything over here?
I guess...
not.
Oh, oh, okay.
Aibo!
So we have to find the scarecrow that is...
It's not actually scary.
Oh, wait!
It's these girls!
Oh my gosh, wait!
I've been so excited to see them!
They're so scary!
These are the girls that were handing out pamphlets at TGX.
Talk to the scarecrow first.
Oh, this guy?
Can't you even imagine how I feel?
I'll put on my polite smile for now.
Well-maintained tool for cutting grass.
It's easy to use, but I have some doubts about how long it will last.
I guess we'll get rid of this guy.
Actually, is it that much better?
Tool.
A giant repulsive lump of flesh.
Need to try, yeah?
Well, let's take note.
bad.
It lumps of flesh that is filled to the brim with a maniacal angler.
It howls awfully as it swings its large knife in any which direction.
Its unfettered anger is no different from that of a wild animal.
No.
It's far worse than that.
Is that this game's pyramid head?
Okay, goodbye.
Second steel pipe.
I hate commitment.
The masks and the, like, the faces on the back, too.
Wait, so who's got a stick up their butt?
Is it that one over there?
That one's got a thing in their back.
Pyramid Head is this game's pyramid head.
Just stick him in the game.
It doesn't matter.
Are they...
Are they, like, moving?
No.
Okay, I thought they were, like...
What's it called?
Um...
I thought they were, uh...
What's the angel?
Weeping angel, yes.
So this one has something stabbed in its back.
Uh-oh, did she get back stabbed?
Is it symbolism?
You?
Oh, it's so scary.
Oh my god, wait, this is awesome.
Oh wait, it does have like a little thing stuck in it.
Is it you?
It doesn't look like she's smiling.
Oh that's right, it did say that it would put on its polite smile, right?
Sometimes I hear like, it sounds like running.
This one's smiling.
Was that me walking or?
Hold on, can it, I'll put on my polite smile for now.
You hear that, right?
Something is moving, it's not me.
Oh, it's that one!
Ah!
So that one, back there, in the middle, is evil.
Okay, okay, okay.
She's not smiling, either.
So freaky.
E!
Oh!
Ouch!
Oh, okay.
That's what that does.
Oh, I didn't realize she would come to life.
I'm such an idiot.
Okay, I- Oh, oh gosh.
Okay.
Ouch!
Wait, can I redo?
Can I restart?
Ah, I didn't realize!
Oh my god, they're tough, too.
Oh, oops, oops.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm gonna die.
I want to restart.
They're fast, yeah.
Oh my god, I'm pressing the wrong button over and over and over again.
I'm such an idiot.
I want to restart.
I messed up.
And
the freaky one's gone, too.
Oh wait, no, she's right there, isn't that?
Her right there.
Oh my god!
Hi!
Oh, she's back.
That's messed up.
Yes, that's definitely the one.
Maybe you?
You're smiling.
What is it, your real face?
Well, I guess that's kind of like the polite smile, huh?
Oh
my god.
Even when I'm examining, she's coming after me.
Freaky one in bottom right?
Maybe this one.
If I die and die!
I did it!
It's okay, you don't have to be afraid anymore.
It's a flashcard.
Is that so?
Is that true?
Oh, that way, okay.
Thank you!
Oh my god.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Just gotta keep running.
Oh, there's more of them.
There's more of them.
Oh, if my game just saved.
Oh no, my game just saved.
Can you imagine how I feel?
What it's like to have been deceived by you for so long.
What does that mean?
Oh, now it updates.
Okay, okay.
What it's like to have been deceived by you for so long.
Assyrius.
I'm going to need you to quit that.
How can I, how am I supposed to tell though, you know?
Stop!
I need to examine!
Like what kind of face is that?
That guy...
That guy looks kind of upset.
Deceived, huh?
Stop it!
I don't think so.
I don't know, I can't tell.
Synonym to be deceived.
Bamboozled.
I was bamboozled by you for so long.
This guy looks pretty upset.
He's like, actually, he's like full frown.
Wait.
He's a full frowning guy.
Maybe not angry enough.
Look for the most bamboozled.
one.
That seems a little...
That guy's happy.
Okay, you're not bamboozled, maybe.
Gotta be careful, though.
She's smiling kind of, too.
I think maybe it's...
He likes the bamboozle.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Let me move the camera.
I don't like that even when I'm examining, it moves.
That freaks me out.
I think it's the guy that was frowning, no?
But also, anyone else hear the occasional footsteps on grass?
It's this guy right there in front of me.
The one that's like ominously close to the guy on the left.
It's that.
It's that little guy.
I feel like I would rather be bamboozled than backstabbed.
word I know I hate weeping angel stuff too I really do especially she's not so fast but just fast enough that it freaks me out I
wish I could see this oh my god oh my god see see see I can't even get a chance to look at the face why do
I feel like it's this guy.
I don't want to be wrong, though.
You think so, too?
I feel like it's this guy.
He looks upset.
I'm gonna try it.
If I die, I die.
Oh,
holy cow.
Oh, my God.
Okay, well, it's not him.
the scarecrow is now, though.
Wait.
I don't know where the scarecrow is now, though, the one following us.
That's pretty bad.
Maybe it's far away.
I can't tell.
You know?
Like, she maybe looks shocked.
Thank God for checkpoints.
Right!
It could be the fact that, also,
She...
Well, that one's looking down too, but she's the only one with like backstabbed.
Actually, you know.
And in the middle.
What are you, the main character?
Let's try it.
Oh, hello?
Are you gonna let me do it?
Oh, the music is killing me.
Let's try her.
Why won't it let me...
There we go.
That's what I said to you.
When I saw you so scared.
That's the way!
Thank you!
These are interesting.
More?
Uh...
Well, she pointed this way, so I'm just gonna keep on going.
Keep on going.
Checking for any mysterious figures behind me.
Oh, oh, oh, right here.
Another.
Another, another, another.
Okay, get him auto-saves, let's go.
Can you even imagine how I feel?
He never once looked at me the way he looked at you.
Not once.
Okay, that's just you being a little jealous, though.
It's not our fault, is it?
Wait.
Isn't that our friend?
Sakuko?
Oh, my bad.
Oh, wait.
What's the journal?
This one.
There we go.
But Sakuko is not the one...
Rinko is the one who's interested, no?
In Shu.
Okay.
Maybe we need to find a girl that looks like...
Dinko.
She also has...
Wait, no, she doesn't have Twin Tail.
I don't remember what Dinko looks like, actually.
Over there?
It's not the...
Short-haired girl, so maybe it's her.
Let's try.
Aha!
I wonder why I called you over.
Thank you.
The music is so scary.
I
thought I heard something moving behind me.
It's so scary.
It's so stinking scary.
It's just run.
Um.
We hit a wall.
Around?
Did you see it?
Did I see what?
Oh gosh, maybe I didn't.
You missed the bakery?
What do you mean?
Here?
Her?
You missed the cake?
Oh, the scarecrow pointing at me.
Oh.
I mean, the way her skirt lays is pretty nice, I'll admit.
Oh, it was worth exploring!
Let's go!
I'm not gonna go all the way back for that.
I mean, I would usually, but...
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
I believe you.
But I'm scared.
I'm scared of cake.
I'm scared of beauty, big, beautiful blushes, booties.
Am I going the right way?
Sorry, the music scared me.
Oh, wait.
What's going on?
Oh.
Why?
No way!
I have to start from the beginning!
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
I made it back here.
Guys, look.
I can see it.
Wow-y!
I don't think he not goes very amused.
You attract what you fear most.
Oh, no.
Huge cake!
Wait.
She- She-
Okay.
Scary, scary, scary, scary.
I
am the bakery.
Cuckoo, cuckoo!
It was so I could see...
Sorry.
Scared the heck out of me.
Where could the next scarecrow be?
I can't tell.
hit the wall and then
follow the wind I am follow the cake the grass blows in the direction if you're lost okay thank you it's actually extremely helpful okay now it's blowing back this way what did I miss okay grass you were literally just opposite direction two seconds ago.
Until you see a group of scarecrows.
Well, I mean, I do hear, but...
Oh.
Uh...
I can't see anything now!
Game!
Please!
You already know I'm lost!
Why are you doing this to me?
I think I'm back at cake.
I'm back at cake
Wait, no, I'm not Oh, this is a game It's just like Okay, idiot Okay, stupid Here you go, we'll just send you there
You know what, that's actually You got close enough I guess, right?
That's actually quite Kind, probably But you guys saw I followed the wind and then it turned around and then it was just like I don't know Can you even imagine how I feel You've always been such an eyesore
An eyesore, right?
Do I find the ugly one?
The ugly one
Or do you think it's one that looks Like me?
Do you think we are Oh, whoops.
Do you think this is like, uh...
What's her name?
Binko's Thoughts.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, she's right there!
I didn't even hear her.
Holy cow.
Ah!
Thank you so much for the Haka Super!
Oh my gosh!
It's my streaming, it makes so many people happy.
Thank you!
What?
Alex, thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh my god.
Stop it!
Stop it, please!
I'm probably gonna have to lead it away, actually.
Because...
I can't get close to them.
Like, MGS3 with all the people you killed?
Oh my gosh, so scary.
I'm not lost!
I'm trying to get her away from here!
So I can figure out the puzzle!
I'm not lost.
I know.
I gotta be able to look at these guys.
For some reason, I feel like it's this one, though.
Stop it.
Stop moving.
Try it.
I guess if I die, I die.
Okay.
It was not that one.
Ah!
You're so scary.
Oh my gosh, I can't read your movements at all.
Vibe check failed.
Me trying to also avoid...
Oh my gosh!
Such an eyesore.
The clue is the one looking at the eyesore.
She's looking at her, right?
But is she looking at him?
The look a mean girl gives.
Well, she's also looking at...
Oh, she looks...
She looks evil!
What about you?
No, she looks normal.
Let's try it.
Wait, oh, she's looking at the eyesore.
Right?
So the eyesore would be this character over here.
here, right?
Oh!
Yeah, she looks so sad.
Oh my god, wait.
The camera, the camera, the camera, the camera, the camera, the camera, the camera, the camera.
I have to turn it.
Oh my god.
Stop, please!
I need to turn the camera!
The eyesore was your first pick.
Wait.
Wait, I'm actually confused.
Am I not supposed to pick the eyesore?
Oh, she's back even!
you need the one looking at the eyesore
okay okay okay hold on I gotta get her away from here real quick
I wonder what she she's like looking at the creature moving so I wonder what's going through her brain as it's like moving closer towards her
okay we gotta do this fast oh my gosh I'm not fast Okay, there we go.
I could have just lied to you.
Told you to go any which way.
Oh!
Thank you very much!
Thank you for your time.
Oh yeah, maybe she's like trying to look at the guy.
But the girl is blocking her view.
Drama!
Yeah, we're moonwalking out of here.
Drama, drama, drama.
Thank you.
Where am I back in the fog?
She's so cute.
Oh, wait, what's happening?
The game took over.
The game was like, no, idiot!
I keep getting lost.
I'm not very good at this.
You must follow the direction indicated by the finger.
Yeah, I know.
And that's the way I went.
I'm gonna try and follow the grass more.
Oh.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Oh, I was stuck on a rock.
Oh my gosh, I could have died.
That's so silly.
I was like, oh, the game's taking over again.
That was a lie.
A moonwalking?
Oh.
What is it?
Oh god.
Take that.
Thank you.
Oh, here we are.
We found it!
Can you imagine how I feel you hurt me and even hurt him too.
Do you know how it feels to force a smile when I'm staring at that disgusting face of yours?
Wait, what are you guys seeing?
Chat, is it me or does her uniform have a little eye, blep eye face?
You see it!
Wait, that's so cute!
That's so stinking cute.
Well, there's so many this time.
So she's...
I see, yeah.
I see...
Wait, is there more than one?
There is!
They kind of, like, have a similar pose.
Like, those two girls are twinning, for real.
Oh, okay.
I think there's, like, three of them?
At least?
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is so difficult.
So it's...
Okay, I have to figure it out really fast!
Okay, um...
Why do I feel like it's this one?
If I die, I die.
But I feel like it's this one because the smile is like upside down on it, you know?
Oh my god, please, please, please, please.
the...
Or this one too.
Damn, these girls got booty.
Do it?
I'll try it.
Like, her face is normal here, but then on the other side, she's smiling.
The mask is smiling, but she's frown, but it's upside down, so it's like she's frowning.
That's my final answer.
Oh my god.
Stop!
Stop it!
I think I might die.
I think I watched eight different players in this segment and still don't know how to know the answers or how to figure it out.
I don't think that's a you problem.
I can't get so close.
Here we go.
Oh, this is so bad.
Oh, um, I'm gonna just die.
Kill me!
I'm not doing two at once.
That's fine.
Okay.
My logic was flawed.
But now I can actually see which ones are real.
Which ones are.
Because of, like, how it's worded, I feel like one...
One side needs to be, like if it's wearing a mask, one side needs to be smiling.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's saying smiling in front of that disgusting face of yours or whatever.
So I feel like maybe this one.
Hmm.
One moment please.
There we go.
A forced two-faced smile.
Exactly, exactly, exactly.
Let's try this one.
I will see.
I'll see.
Come
here, Mrs.
Okay.
Oh no, my thing is about to break.
Maybe it's the other way around.
This one's smiling.
Is it you?
Is this your fake smile?
The bit about being hurt matters for this one.
So it's, like, stabbed or something.
I mean, there's this guy, but I feel like it's not...
I feel like it wouldn't be one of the guys, is it?
Or am I crazy?
Are we out the backseat?
Not yet!
I'm not yet.
I'm still trying to figure out.
It's okay.
You hurt me and even hurt him, too.
So maybe it is this guy, then.
backstabbed, but he's smiling at the girl.
Let's try.
I'm so bad at this.
Oh, please.
Lock on here, Will.
Oh, my gosh.
So many hits.
So she just says that sometimes.
I really don't think it's one.
Maybe it's this one.
I feel like there's no smile, so...
Why not?
Let's just pull all of them at this rate.
Oh my god.
My weapon's gonna break!
Fruit Force!
I'm not really good at deciphering this one.
That's like...
Maybe I'm just like...
What's the word?
Oh, oh, my weapon's broken.
Did I get her?
No, not yet.
The first two weren't so bad.
Or the first couple weren't so bad.
It's this one that is getting me all...
I'll jumble.
The first...
Yeah, I could get the other ones, but this one, I'm like, huh?
And that one, I also thought it was the long-haired girl because she's looking at...
someone else I mean she's not forced to smile you know so I feel like it's probably one like I imagine I was like oh it's probably one that's looking at someone else with a smile you know maybe it's this one where it's upside down again like kind of like oh she's she's smiling because she's upside down but it's actually a frown did I try this one before
Like it's looking at him, so he's looking at her, and she's like, yeah, and she's looking at...
Did I try this one?
I can't remember.
Every single person I watch play this has struggled a lot.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Thank you for the reassurance.
Let's try this one.
Okay, but I don't feel like my logic was so flawed there, okay?
I feel like that made total sense.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, God.
Okay.
I'm using all my stuff, though.
It sucks.
Okay, now I can...
That was, like, my most logical...
Already!
No way!
Oh, my gosh.
I feel like that was my most logical explanation.
It was...
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, my.
Oh my god!
Evil, evil, evil, evil!
Wait, why did I do that?
All my stamina.
I feel like that was my most logical.
Girl with the knife in the back near the boy with the knife in the back.
I did her!
I've done so many of these guys at this point.
Her?
This one?
Wait, didn't I do this?
Maybe I didn't do this one.
I guess...
Let me see if I did it or not.
Oh my god.
It happens all the time.
A kid falling to their death in the waterway.
I don't even feel good about that.
Finding it out.
Because it was so confusing.
Oh
my god.
Oh,
there's shoe over there.
I see him.
Wait, there's shoe right there.
Wait, but I see...
I see shoe over there.
Wait, why do I see...
Wait, why do I see double shoe?
Wait, is it supposed to be like that or is it bugs?
Well, shoes right there!
A pair of shoes.
One whole year in Minto, today is my birthday.
I'm going to spend it the same way I did last year.
Ah, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear.
I see a light.
I hope I said your name right.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Guys, why do we have double shoes?
Two shoes.
Oh, look at it.
Hinako.
Rinako?
A pair of shoes.
She like so clearly is so...
But, there's no one else.
I see no one else's bad old girl.
I'm like, this is absolutely weird.
There's no one else.
There's so many bad creatures that are all around the world.
I don't know what to do with it.
Yeah, real subtle wrinkle.
You got any steel pipes in there?
You got any pipes that we can borrow, wrinkle?
Oh,
the doll is right there.
Why?
But everyone's disappeared.
You guys can swim, right?
Oh my god.
Again, you guys can swim, right?
That's actually not even that bad of like a swim.
Oh no.
Yes, please.
Please.
Okay, thank you.
I don't know why they're so scared of the water.
Just go push you down the stairs, girl.
evil!
Hello!
And Shu probably didn't hear a dang thing.
Gosh!
Scarecrow's whispers, as you bask in the sun, I sink into the shadows is what the achievement I just got.
Basking.
We're back here with our sexy fox guy.
Yeah, we didn't see a push.
I thought that too.
But...
Oh.
I'm lagging hard, sorry.
Creepy fox, man.
Why am I lagging so bad?
Aw, we were supposed to get bandages and stuff from her.
No!
No, our supply run!
Aw, man.
Evil.
Why does this board look like a trap?
Hello!
I hope there's no board really scary guys in here.
Those are so scary.
Oh, there's someone over there.
Is that him?
Oh, of course he does.
Of course, of course he shuts the door on us.
Of course.
Oh, it's giving me a lot of things to do and I'm...
I'm not reading them.
Oops.
What's over here?
A whole lot of nothing.
He closed the door on my face.
He's into me.
Scale of 1 to 10, how spooky is this game?
I think it's pretty spooky.
I like it.
So far, so calm.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Yeah, I like the atmosphere.
a lot.
It's like my favorite kind of atmosphere, basically, for, like, scary things, so I'm really... That's why I'm so scared because I'm so into it.
Let's not...
It's about to say, what's in here?
It's like a storage area.
I think the stuff... The crash came from over here, I think.
Oh my gosh.
Camera.
Maybe not.
Oh, It is letting me go inside though.
For what purpose?
Huh.
Anything I can take?
Open?
Ah.
Messy scrolls.
Wonder what that pretty little thing's chirps will sound like when I tear off that mask of hers.
The girl before last was an exquisite specimen.
I can barely contain myself every time I think about her.
I told you he's into me!
Oh no.
Anybody out there?
No?
Okay.
What was that?
What the way is that?
Thank you for the divine water, I guess.
And nothing else.
So scared.
We'll go, uh...
Oh, there's more.
Wait, this place is huge!
We'll go this way since the sounds are...
That's what I'm doing!
Since the sounds are...
Who?
Oh my gosh, the camera angles really...
Wait, was this a door?
Did I miss it?
Oh, okay.
Find the... Okay, the sacred door.
This place is humongous!
Okay.
Oh,
okay, hold on.
I feel a little lost.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
There's another room even.
Wait, I thought we were outside.
Suddenly we're inside.
What's going on here?
What's the puzzle?
Oh, no, there's like little artifacts.
I have to remember these artifacts.
Okay.
What's in there?
Nothing.
Can't even open this.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
I'm a little stressed.
Nothing.
Wait, can I leave?
I don't want to be inside here.
Yeah, why will you let me open two drawers and they both have nothing in them?
It's pretty rude.
Ah.
I should have.
I should have expected it.
Yeah, yeah.
Save was right back that way.
Oh, was it?
Thank you so much.
Where I was headed to?
Well, it's kind of forcing me in that direction anyway, so.
We'll go through here.
room key ah oh my game just saved
we're praying we're praying i use so many with the supplies in the foggy area oh wait this is silent hill it's all foggy Howdy, howdy!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
For one whole month!
Thank you, thank you!
Um... But... I mean, the scarecrow area?
I almost wanted to, like, restart, but...
Wait.
Oh, yeah, what is that?
It's like a big ol...
Okay.
Cool.
Hmm.
Naginato.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's what it's called.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't...
I didn't remember.
I'm not good at remembering things like that.
Okay, then let's go back to the storage room.
Let's go over here.
Explore just a tad.
Just a smidge of exploration.
Exploration.
I was, there was like a scrape on the, what's it called?
The pole and I was wondering if it was a claw mark.
Scary.
Fucking not.
What is that sound?
Okay, let's try that door.
I'm guessing.
Oh, it's highlighted.
Wait, does that mean that that's where the key goes?
I don't want to know what's over here anyway.
Just the wind.
Just the wind, of course.
Of course, of course, of course.
Of course.
This looks awfully suspicious.
Like a great place to hide, huh?
Okay.
Moinari-sama's emblem.
Mmm.
Minto.
That's me.
Okay, so I go back this way.
This place is going to get me all backwards.
Sorry, I'm going to be, like, opening up the map every two seconds, I fear.
I'm not a fan of what we might be releasing.
We weren't in here before, were we?
Oh, my doll!
Gonna have nightmares with this area?
The doll that we don't know to trust or not.
She's looking right at me.
If there was something there, I missed it.
Oh.
Yeah, it's saying to don't trust the fox guy.
Don't believe the fox's words!
Stay away from the western room.
Who's Ember?
Oh.
my gosh yesterday i carried up i uh had to carry a big package i didn't realize that it was gonna be so heavy i had to carry it for a long time and now my arms are jelly a warning kinako is mine her fingers her lips every last drop of blood that can be squeezed from her is mine i forbid anyone from laying so much as a finger on her i shall say it until my throat is is raw.
Hinako is mine.
I told you he wants me.
I told you.
Wait, so who do we believe, though?
Our childhood doll?
Or the guy that's kind of been helping us?
Probably.
Maybe not the guy anymore.
Um, guys.
I think he likes us.
What is West again?
I don't remember.
Is it Nishi?
Wait.
Am I stupid?
In Japanese, sorry.
It is Nishi.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's a dame!
Whoa, look at the mask there.
Cool.
A little freak.
Hinako, you're so in.
Yeah, Hinako, you have nothing to be worried about.
He's obsessed with you.
Well, now I'm not quite sure where to go.
Ah, I see, I see.
Now...
Wait, West.
So this is the West Room.
That's what she's saying.
I believe then.
I don't think there was anything in here.
I feel like I combed it pretty well.
You heard the doll.
Don't go.
What do you mean time to choose?
Do I have another choice?
I don't think I have a choice, do I?
The game says go.
What does the fox say?
I'm going to the West Room.
I'm so sorry I'm a curious cat.
If you are a fox.
Oh, I thought that was like fan art.
Oh, what could that be possibly blocking on the other side?
What could possibly be lurking over there?
Is this his room?
Wait a second.
Is this like stages of Hinako?
Mysterious.
They all have no faces.
This one just totally doesn't have a head.
That's my favorite, actually.
I'm in your room!
I'm so sorry, Mr. Fox!
It's once again telling me not to believe him, not to trust him.
But hold on, before I...
Before I activate...
Oh, maybe...
Actually, maybe that will activate it.
Don't trust him!
So cute!
Yeah, I might have a thing for headless women.
it's like kind of like Dolahan and also oh my gosh wait have you guys seen that figure series of like invisible girls I don't know the brand off of the top of my head but they often do like it'll be like a seifuku and like the skirt will be blowing up but because the girl is invisible you can't see anything oh my gosh it's so good oh it's so good and then there's like hold on you haven't seen it okay hold on hold on this is important enough for me to pause the game real quick one second one second i've been wanting these figures for so long now it's really cleverly made they look so so good oh but if i could just remember what the ah what the you know the modeler like this the company They just put out something new recently and I was looking at it.
Hold on, let me go through my history.
My...
Ami-Ami-Ami history.
Okay, it wasn't recent enough, I suppose.
Heroism?
I don't think...
I'm not sure.
Hold on.
Let me look up like Seifuku.
That'll probably give me like the most stuff ever.
Oh, it does.
Sailor Fuku.
Saylor, Fuku.
This is important.
You guys, I'm showing you.
I'm showing you peak.
Okay?
It's so good.
I promise.
It's worth it.
It is Heroism Studio.
It is.
It's not showing me if I look it up.
It's not showing me.
Wait, I think also recently they did a ghost one, you know, kind of like how I am me and Mama did that ghost of me and the shit.
Ah, ha!
I found it.
I found the ghost, but this one, wait, is this the same brand?
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
But this one, she's not invisible.
Hold on.
Okay, I found some of them.
They're so good, you guys.
They're so good.
Oh my gosh.
Like, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look.
I love, you know me, I love Monster Girls, and so this is kind of like, just...
It's like this one she's like lift is okay.
Oh my gosh.
I can't get over it.
I can't get over how cool they are Okay, hold on It's like just feels like monster girl enough.
You know what I mean?
Okay, all right.
I'll show you the first and they're not very pricey So there's this one Wait This one
Look!
Look how cool!
Oh my gosh, it's so, it's like the sexiest thing I've ever seen ever.
It's so, it's so good.
Oh, what did I just move?
I don't know.
Oh, that's okay.
It's so stinking sexy.
And then there's this one, which like, it's summertime and she's lifting up her shirt having the air blow tights
oh my gosh it's so it's so sexy it's so sexy and then this is the most recent one and i'm pretty sure it's still for sale on amy amy if you wanted to look for it but this one i won't show you the back you can look that up yourself it's so good uh the brand is chiu c-h-i-y you yes yes this one is 7400 yen oh wait they're all still available oh wow the first one this one is 9700 yen and then this one is 7700 yen and then they okay i'll show you the ghost one too because i mentioned it even though it's not an invisible girl but it's so it's so cute this one Look out good!
This is what I mean when I say less is more.
Like, you can show so little and it, like, is so sexy, you know?
Like, this?
It's so sexy.
Oh, they're so good.
They're so good!
Okay, anyway.
I'll go back to the game now.
I'm a little less scared.
It's not that I'm shilling Ami Ami, but I only mention Ami Ami so often because they're the only site that I use.
So, okay.
Hmm.
Back to game.
We're going to take whatever the heck this thing is.
Inari sculpture.
A sculpture in the image of the god Inari.
It looks like it might fit somewhere.
We saw a room.
that had uh what's it called oh was it this one I'm scared something's gonna come after me once I walk out of here okay yeah the emblem room exactly exactly
oh no oh it just gives me a full full no way okay Interesting.
I didn't see anything.
I guess maybe we go back to that one place with the long sword.
Spooky, spooky, spooky, spooky, spooky, spooky.
Spooky, spooky, spooky.
My hands are so sweaty.
If I were scared...
And...
I'm playing this game.
But just still, let me hold your hand.
If I'm so scared.
Even though my hands are sweaty.
Which is, does that mean?
Still?
Wait, am I lost?
Yes.
No.
I'm not lost.
I might get your hand covered in ectoplasm.
Is that okay?
Scared.
Okay, not here.
Um...
Huh.
Mom spaghetti.
Yeah, exactly.
What did I miss?
Where was a spot where I could...
Place it.
Wait, did I go this way?
Oh, I didn't!
Oh my gosh, I didn't even go this way.
I'm so silly.
What does a Yohkan do again?
Some good merch shilling.
If only there was a recent min-merch that said- Oh yeah, I have merch!
I wish there was a link showing me where to get a min-merch!
Yeah!
I'll have to link it.
Okay, greatly restores health, okay, I'll remember that.
I have merch!
Sorry, I forgot.
Don't tell Shatana, Shatana.
There are valuable relics hidden away in an old storage room.
They must be kept under lock and key.
The last girl slipped in while I wasn't looking.
It took a long time to find her.
That's not... that couldn't be this room, right?
That wouldn't be this.
Oh, I think he goes there!
Investigate the strange object.
Okay.
Thanks, Kim.
Now, Hara, does this open up or something?
Cute!
Oh, this opens up.
Yeah, what other girl?
I thought you were into me.
The game saved, so...
Grab that.
An exquisitely crafted ornamental pole armor.
that is extremely sturdy and able to be used as a weapon.
KURNA!
Oh my god.
Oh, I didn't mean to attack, but it's a good thing I did.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
What are you doing in here?
ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Is this the other girl, maybe?
Oh, oopsie.
I got ahead of myself.
New weapon acquired.
Can I have my thing back please?
Thank you.
The fire's gone out.
Aw, man.
Okay.
Is this the X?
Yeah.
Oh.
Whoa.
Freaky.
This...
I think this is an important thing.
Sorry, I'm going to go.
Tattered paper.
The inscription on the pole arm reads, Also known as Inadama.
Inadama is another way for Inazuma, meaning lightning.
This likely refers to the unique pattern of the blade's steel.
To the door!
Here we go!
Oh, this looks so ominous!
Wait, there's a save right here too!
Okay, cool!
What do you mean here we go?
What do you mean by that?
So it is a boss.
Not a feeling.
We finally arrived.
What's over here?
One moment, please.
I'm investigating.
Is she hard?
The boss?
I forgot to investigate the door, actually.
Saku goes in the afterlife.
Something's supposed to go here too.
Oh yeah, he's got something.
This key is the same one as before.
Yeah,
I'm totally gonna lower my caution, my defenses when my dead friend is calling out to me with a creepy, ghastly echo.
That's like me being like, hey, wisps, come over here.
to be afraid of just follow the sound of my voice okay wow it's so beautiful reminds me of tangled i'm gonna cry oh oh my gosh seriously okay let's go ram actually there might be another one on the other side let's take care of this thing oh never mind she left
what was the sneak attack it was like a full focus and then oh my god the way she's running seems suspicious ask if she has 500 yen to pay you back right
okay hold on i am gonna go around the other way then
focus and when they shake red attack No, I think that's the counter, right?
I'm talking about the sneak attack that I failed last time, too.
That's okay.
You can't win them all.
Is she gonna notice me?
Yeah, she's a little stupid.
There is a sneak attack.
There was a whole tutorial for it.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh!
Ouch!
Oh, nice.
Took care of her.
It's not a sneak attack, just a focus attack that deals heavy damage.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, yeah, the journal had a tutorial, huh?
Maybe it was just a...
Maybe I thought it was a sneak attack.
Stamina, sanity...
Oh, yeah, here we go.
It's like to use of focus and psychological attacks from enemies.
I'm not in a state of focus.
Ah, okay, okay, okay, okay.
stamina is dealing with my focus.
Taking psychological damage.
Once you have no sanity left, your health will take damage instead.
Dodging.
Fleeing.
Yeah, I do that a lot.
Attacks.
Focus.
Hmm.
Use RB to perform the focus attack.
That might have been it.
Okay.
Anyway, not quite sure if these guys recover or not yet, so I don't want to hang her.
I don't want to linger, you know?
She was kind of messy.
It's so funny.
There's, like, ink all over in here.
She looked like a...
Like a...
Barbie doll that's been played by a kid.
Greatly decreases focus charging time.
Thank you.
Okay.
Any bandages?
Any health items?
Okay.
That's fine.
That's fine too.
Oh.
Divine water.
Okay, that part is blocked off.
I could tell from here.
I just wanted to make sure.
Saku-ko!
Aww.
You're not- you're not, Saku-ko!
Oh, shoot.
I did the wrong thing.
Okay.
That was pretty smooth.
I like this weapon.
I hope I get to keep it forever.
Yes.
Slip on in there.
Oh.
Oh, okay!
This is fine.
Um...
Housemaid's note!
Made...
February 15th.
There can be no two ways about it.
The family is indeed cursed.
Wait, hold on, maybe.
And I am the only one who knows the full story.
I must tell the master all I know, for if I do not, the curse will certainly befall me as well.
May the gods have mercy on me.
the lighting is like so strong in some of these areas i could feel like i would see like a shadow of one of them walking by or something like that you know very spooky scary amy physicians log february 1st symptoms at onset are as following as follows headache fever vertigo chills vomiting diarrhea at first i believe signs pointed to a seasonal cold however after prescribing medicine symptoms did not improve in fact they worsened Me!
That's me!
Yeah, I'm pretty cursed.
For those who don't know.
Like, actually.
I mean, it's pretty cursed already that I'm dead, no?
The Crimson Spring... Spring gushing from the womb.
Deep within is the Shimizu family.
How?
Wait, what?
The Crimson Spring gushing from the womb?
What was that?
Was that the sound of the thing we're covering?
Like the monster outside?
Sorry, I'm moving the camera around like crazy right now.
So sorry, so sorry.
I just realized I was doing it.
Like in such an erratic way.
I'm just like exploring everything.
I did miss one.
I missed one.
Oh, here.
Not enough.
The honorable blood fill it up.
Make it full.
Otherwise.
Did I miss another note?
Maybe over here.
Ah, wait.
Oh, I got this.
okay we continue on board I think that's it okay on the floor what do you mean on the floor on the right wait what I missed it oh thank you family physicians log February 8th the patients condition are conditions are declining suddenly and rapidly symptoms are as follows labored breathing
quadriplegia.
What is that?
You've convinced me I bought one of the invisible girls you should.
Oh, it's so good.
I don't have one.
I should get one, but yeah.
I hope it, I hope it.
Tell me how it is.
Oh, paralysis.
Involuntary movements, in addition to these, an even stranger's symptom has arisen.
The patient's facial features appear to be deforming.
The patient's faces remain stuck in expressions of constant strain their teeth bared their eyes narrowed into a menacing glare freaky what is it olivander's one one shot is the one chop in the
my did my game just save
Come here, come here.
Sakuko, don't run away.
Don't run away from me, Sakuko.
She'll be afraid of me.
Maybe.
I'm scared.
I knew there was no way Sakuko could be gone, though, you know, like.
I just didn't expect it right now.
I'm checking my corners.
Research notes on Enmye Jugonoku Or is it Sakuko at all?
The wish to have one's romantic desires fulfilled is as old as humanity itself Consequently, there have existed many arts by which people attempt to make such dreams come true One such method was to employ a sorcerer Known as a Jugonji to perform an incantation written in the Enmi Jujugon Roku After such spells were suspected of causing chaos and turmoil in the imperial court,
their practice was expressly forbidden under the Yoro Code in the first year of the Tempio Hoji era 757 AD Magic Riz That's just a love potion guys Oh my gosh However, these incantations were later adopted into the practice of Omniodo, where their effects continue to be studied according to multiple sources powerful and romantic spells have been successfully cast that have been successfully cast are often accompanied by the scent of sandalwood yummy it sounds sounds good wait so like if i got like so that like sandalwood candle i got wait do i have to run all the way back here once i have the thing dried carcass
Yeah.
Wait, I have to run all the way back here to get to the door.
An animal carcass that has been properly packaged as an offering.
It gives off a vague odor.
Oh, no!
Okay, hold on.
I hear her.
I hear them.
Find out where the voice is coming from.
They put Fami Tiki in the game!
I was trying to figure out which direction it's in, but...
It sounds right next to me.
Maybe to my left?
Nope, to my right.
Just kidding!
Oh my god!
I was right the first time.
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
No!
I got grabbed!
Ah, that sucks.
Oh, that sucks.
I tried to do the special attack.
And I was not very good at it.
I should have... I don't know why I didn't wait for them to glow red, but whatever.
Oh well.
Yeah, go onwards.
I hear another one.
This is insanity.
Am I going to have to go through all of this again?
All the way back here?
Okay.
Oh, God.
Hold on.
I'm, like, remembering the route a little bit.
So we go through the library.
Jose Horror Game?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, there's two of them.
I heard another one.
Just use fast travel.
Yeah!
Forehand.
I heard...
Did it
go onward?
Ah.
Dead end.
Okay.
Ah.
Okay, I go...
Okay, I came from here.
And so I go here and around.
What are you?
Lakazuti.
Slowly restore his health and current max sanity for a set time.
Also, we can be used as an offering.
I
think I should hold on to what I have for now.
Maybe there was only...
I could have sworn I heard too.
Oh gosh, it's coming back.
So...
scary oh i don't think it comes this way maybe it does oh no it doesn't
i think i have to kill it
though what's oh my god i'm so oh there were two oh i'm gonna die here i'm gonna die here aren't i oh i knew there were two
I'm gonna die!
I couldn't dodge, it was still... my stamina was still loading.
That's okay, that's okay.
Oh, okay, we're here, we're here.
Where?
Oh, I didn't notice him walking in the back before!
That's so freaky.
See, it's stuff like that that I really, really love.
Just little tiny details where...
You would never know!
You would never know.
Um, wait.
I think it was just this guy here.
But I also know that it's to my left this time.
I'm gonna go to the little ghosty's room real fast.
I'm gonna go to the little ghosty's room real right quick and I will be right back and then we will continue.
I want to get... you guys think I will be able to beat the boss today.
what do you guys think is it like so long from now
yeah boss easy oh thank you okay i'll be right back then let me check in let me put my thing uh there we go okay okay baby
okay baby i'm back sorry about that So sorry, so sorry.
Oh, thank you for that.
Let's open the egg and die well.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now that I know that there's two for sure, I was not so sure before.
Now I'm sure.
I'm sure.
Oh, wow.
Okay, dokie.
Let's do this.
Oh.
And I grabbed the chicken.
I should have trusted my ears.
I knew it was to my left.
Oh gosh, wait.
It really sucks that there's no way to like get out of that.
Oh, it really sucks.
Oh well.
So much crazy damage.
Alright, so what we need to do is definitely take on one at a time.
So we'll take out this guy first.
Grabs are meant to be punishing.
It sucks, it sucks, it sucks.
How much damage?
It doesn't have higher difficulty?
I'm afraid.
I'm afraid they don't even know.
I don't know where the other one comes from, though.
Like, I know there's too, but where does she come from?
You know?
Ah,
indeed.
Ah, indeed.
Oh my gosh, I'm trapped!
Ah!
Oh my gosh, I couldn't get out.
I didn't realize I was against the...
There we go.
Okay.
There's one down at least.
Oh.
Wait, do I need the Trigger her being like, Let's go!
I'm not gonna care.
Okay.
Let's...
Let's go.
I don't know where the other one comes from.
Oh, from the ceiling.
That's why.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I don't think we can run from her, can we?
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm so screwed.
Wait.
I screwed myself.
Oh, I screwed myself!
I screwed myself!
Ah!
I have no stamina!
Which is so bad.
Guys, guys, uh, I'm screwed.
Oh my god.
Okay, you can't run.
The game is like, sometimes you gotta run!
It lies to you!
That wasn't so good.
That was pretty bad, actually.
It's really bad.
That was a...
Okay, don't run.
Why is it gotta be empty?
Sometimes I hear like something that sounds like laughing.
It's pretty...
You hear it?
I don't know if you can...
It's too soft on your eyes, isn't it?
It's like a...
Oh, how nice.
Wait, I can offer...
You.
Yahoo!
Oh, we're...
Wait, how much was it to upgrade?
500.
We can either get a new Omamori, or we can...
Upgrade.
I think upgrading is more important right now.
Yawkan.
Oh, cool.
I just had to use one.
Divine Water.
Okay, what do we have?
What's my supplies at the moment?
Upgrades are good?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm thinking that.
Honestly, I feel like my own my body... I mean, oh, I only have one slot.
It kind of sucks.
Max stamina.
Max health.
Decrease focus charging time.
Decrease enemy line of sight.
It greatly decreases the damage taken while dodging.
Hey, y'all, y'all.
Hey, y'all.
I wanted to ask this on a Silent Hill F-stream.
Pick a favorite prefecture.
Should have gotten a letter And two or three digit number If it's too much to add Much, it's okay Um I think I understand what you're doing Okay, let's see Um Maybe a favorite prefecture I can I see And then Should have gotten a letter Hmm Hmm you for you day and then two or three digit number well we can't do four fours because you said two or three uh wait oh ah three ten for minto three ten minto you can use focus to time the counter
It's a skill issue.
What am I hearing laughing though?
Okay, I'm not running.
I'm not running at all anymore.
I'm taking my damn sweet time.
Okay.
Did my game just save?
Is that what I just saw?
Stone orb.
This seems to be made from the same material as the stone key that the moss...
The moss...
Appalachians saying things wrong.
Fox mask had given to me.
Maybe it serves a similar purpose.
Oh, oh, big, big change in atmosphere.
What was that?
Girl, if it were me, I'd just be booked.
Oh my god!
Wait,
am I going the right way?
Sorry.
Wait, uh...
Uh...
Yes, I need to go...
Okay, okay.
Sorry.
Wait, uh, sorry.
Okay, to the left.
Ah, okay.
I should have known.
We're running, we're running, we're running.
We're running, we're running.
We're running.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh...
I'm gonna name that doll thing.
Junior.
No, why would you do that?
Okay.
Um, okay.
It doesn't, I guess we could go around if we totally need to, but I don't want to.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I'm dodging, I'm dodging.
Oh gosh, I'm dodging, and I'm running, and I'm running.
Okay, whoo!
Yay, we did it!
That wasn't so bad.
I feel like the other guys were way scarier.
Way more.
Okay, we did it!
Can we go back to Asana Hill now?
Find Fox Mask.
Okay, we don't.
Okay, understandable.
Oh yeah, I didn't read these yet.
at least.
A monster that pretends to be a scarecrow.
It's dressed in old clothes and looks like a crucified corpse from far away.
Contrary to its name, it scares more kids off than crows.
What did I miss?
Oh, I guess that's it.
Baby.
Oh, a monster that possesses sharp blades for legs.
Sexy.
Does someone sever both of its legs and replace them with such disturbing things?
anywhere?
Or was this creature brought into existence just so it could end up like this?
I'm blocking it, but there's like cute little tiny doodles in the corners as well.
I'm blocking it.
You can kind of see it when I flip the page.
A bizarre monster that looks like a bunch of celluloid dolls intertwined.
Each of these dolls was most likely some child's best friend.
To think that they would appear like this in my nightmare.
What do we got here?
Less hand mirror.
when taking fatal damage from normal attacks this mirror will break instead.
Health, sanity, and stamina will be fully restored.
Oh no.
What's my health like at anyway?
Take that bandage for sure.
Wait, why is it giving me so much stuff?
Wait a second.
Wait, there's like a ton of stuff here.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Wait!
I should probably start saving over these.
Okay!
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Freaky.
Um...
What was the thing that I...
Oh, it was another first...
It hit kit?
I believe?
Let's get rid of a divine water.
And then we can upgrade.
Maybe.
Yes, we can.
Let's get rid of a divine water.
And the Yohkan!
I'll keep, because I think I'll use it.
This restores stamina.
Let's just get rid of this, and then we can upgrade.
But what should I upgrade is the biggest thing.
My health, my sanity, stamina.
I can't do all my body shots just yet, but.
Stamina.
I think, honestly, stamina for dodging is, like, huge.
Stamina screwed you last time.
Exactly, exactly, exactly.
So I think stamina will be the way that I go.
Your prayers were heard, you now have more stamina!
Yippee!
What are we looking at?
Okay.
Alright, all my health is here.
Oh wow, I didn't even realize that the thing I'm using doesn't even have durability.
That's really nice.
And then the big first aid kit is here if I need it.
Alright, I'm gonna save one more time.
Okay.
Naginata.
I never remember the name.
Can I take this now?
Dang.
Only one at a time.
No!
If you donate one more divine water, you can fit that.
Can I?
Will it stack?
Nice, thank you.
What does the divine- sorry, I can't remember what these items do at all for some reason.
Okay, that's the sanity.
Okay.
this one.
Oh, another first aid kit.
Uh-oh.
What are they trying to say, huh?
Oh, gosh.
Goodbye, other divine water.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, because the divine water was stacked.
Ah!
What do?
It needs its own slot.
It's fine.
Maybe.
I don't think it's fine.
What if I got rid of my peels?
Probably good with only two.
Let's try if I die.
I just restart.
I just retry.
It's all good.
Use one then grab it.
People are saying sell it all.
Why?
Why do you want me to have no items?
Why do you want me to have nothing?
I need health!
Why do you want me to die?
I guess I could sell all the divine water.
I don't think I'll use it, honestly.
Do that.
Just don't get hit.
Yeah, forehead.
Alright, RB.
And it's Y.
Okay.
Is that him?
No, I don't think so.
I
don't...
Oh!
Oh, that's some big old mighty...
Those are like...
Oh, I was...
Her tears.
Ooh.
Oh, girl.
I was right!
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh, that's got some length on it.
Uh-oh.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
Sakuko like entity.
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh!
Ah!
Holy cow!
She hits like crazy!
Okay, I'm gonna have to start healing for real.
Golly!
Holy cow.
Oh, whoops.
That's not my match first.
They're real.
Oh, shit.
I'm not a traitor.
I don't mean to.
You got my money?
Sakugong?
Oh my, what the heck?
That felt kind of dirty.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh!
What is going on with my attacks?
Wait, wait, dodge this?
Wait, I should probably, like, heal.
Ooh, that was a good timing.
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't know why sometimes I think why is...
The...
I tried dodging.
Not good enough.
Dodge!
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit!
I think I had just enough...
stamina to do it!
Oh, that was so close.
That was so, so close.
Oh my gosh, I need...
I don't get in fast enough, you know?
Ah!
Thank you!
Oh,
phase two!
Uh-oh.
What is going on here?
Oh, it does hurt me, though.
Oh, my sanity is going crazy.
Hold on.
Oh, geez.
Let's full heal.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my gosh.
I think I need to...
Okay.
Ah, even with the comeback!
Oh, gosh.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, I have no stamina.
I tried dodging.
Yeah!
Gosh!
Okay, nice.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Where is she?
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch.
Sorry, I'm so focused right now.
Yeah!
I
was so focused.
Why?
Eww!
Freaky.
Can we trust this guy?
What do you mean an evil?
This happened before?
She lives.
Okay.
I mean, honestly, the doll is like don't trust him, but what other choice do we have?
We're stuck here, otherwise, what do we do?
Good luck at work!
We're ending right after this too, so don't worry, you're not missing too much after this.
I'm taking a bath?
Let's go.
It's so noisy.
There are footsteps.
Okay.
Oh, did we drink it?
You like rinse your mouth out.
Wow, how Japanese.
Duck, no!
I wonder she became a Yankee.
Your turn!
So, you, me more.
Hi.
She just starts taking off her clothes to like get in the bath.
What?
She looked like me when I used that filter.
Um, sir?
Are we seeing the same thing?
I think it's evil water.
Maybe the doll is like, don't do it!
Something really doesn't want her to do this.
That's what I'm saying.
She looks sweaty.
Maybe she does need a bath.
I know I do.
I'm sweaty too.
It's okay.
We're both the same.
Why does she look like a hamster?
Me when I eat nacho cheese.
cleansed washed thoroughly before eating is the achievement i got
oh wow ninko we can tell you i fell down the stairs and became unconscious and you're just gonna be like wow it's okay stupid what are you what are you
Look at the way she's staring at her.
She looks so scary.
Dinko, you freak!
Let's go.
First, let me raid your house.
Of all your belongings.
Let's go.
I think that's what he meant by he goes in the front and Hinako goes in the back She's so scary.
Doki bird behavior.
That's some real Doki bird behavior.
Let me stay in the middle.
Okay, Shu's house.
Sakuko.
Sakuko is very in touch with her spiritual side.
She seems to always have some god or apparition visiting her dreams, telling her about this or her.
that according to Sakako there's been quite the supernatural disturbance around Ebisugaoka something about an ancient god who's furious about having their followers stolen from them and now they're out for revenge or what not where's a place for me to save though somewhere please can we go back inside her house and take her things
It's not far?
Okay.
I'm just stealing stuff right now.
I heard also that in this game there's a Silent Hill 1 reference.
Is that true?
Like very small.
I want to find it.
Should be one up ahead?
Okay, good.
No!
Is it the fog?
Yeah.
the fog it's the fog the only thing it could be right oh
i guess oh it's the same one as before okay good good good panic thank you so much for the gift thank you thank you thank you i don't know iro fog was a silent hill reference i know that's why when you see fog you are like legally obligated to say wow feels very silent hill here like that you're supposed to say like This feels like Sala Hill.
Anytime it's foggy outside.
Konami will bust down your door and tell you.
Wait, if I change into bunny, does the sleeve still rip?
Let's check it out.
I hear, like, movement.
It scares me.
No, well, thank you so much for that, Tony.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It is!
It is ripped!
Look how cute... Wait.
Oh my gosh, the like jiggle on the...
on the ears and the tail are so cute.
As far as I can tell, you never played Silent Hill 1.
How would I...
How would I get the reference?
Well, lucky I know Silent Hill.
Okay.
Anyway.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna call it here!
I hear footsteps.
Like over in this way.
Hinako's rock at the Temple of Doom.
I don't know if you guys hear it too.
Nice gaming, Minto!
Thank you!
There we go!
Thank you so much for the peek!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I keep hearing footsteps, and I want to chat, but it's stressing me out a little.
But anyway, this was fun.
I wanted to make way more progress this time than I did last time since I only got to play for a tiny bit before.
But we made it through the big meaty man, and we made it through Sakako, question mark.
So I feel satisfied.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Great progress.
I had a lot of fun.
So, we will continue next time.
I might.
I don't know.
I want to do, like, more horror games, and obviously this is a horror game, so um, like more games.
I want to do, like, a couple games a week since it's Halloween.
So, Um, yeah, maybe we'll do, like, this game twice a week or something so I can get through it.
Yes, yes, yes.
More horror, more spooky!
Spooky, spooky, spooky.
Even though it's scary, scary, scary, scary.
Anyway, I had so much fun.
Hinako, do you have anything you want to say?
She's shy.
Make me thank you!
Great progress.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I have not played Soma, so maybe that will be something I play on the list, you know.
Isn't that a one-shot?
Like, I could do it in one stream or two.
It's not super duper long from what I...
No.
But anyway, I hate those scarecrows.
They were so cool, though.
They looked so good.
Like, they were so spooky.
Yeah, I'm really enjoying the game.
I know, like, a lot of people complain about the combat being a little clunky, but honestly, see that's feels like silent hills but i had fun and i have you guys too and i will see you when i see you next thank you so much for the stream and i will see you later bye bye bye bye bye bye bye thank you it's a bito